Hi everybody. It's a real pleasure to
be here today to talk to you about, um,
fecal microbiota transplants and some
of the work that OpenBiome and finish up
and doing a,
I'm Kevin Roloffs.
I'm a research scientist at finch
working on microbial isolation and we are
really, and I'm really excited
to tell you about our mission,
our shared mission to harness the
power of the human microbiome.
We'll just start off with a few basic
facts about the human microbiome.
So this is one of my favorite,
uh, artistic depictions
of the human micro biome.
It's just like kind of shows off like
the huge amount of bacteria that are
covering every surface of us.
Uh, and they're on your skin,
they're on your teeth, they're all
inside of your alimentary tract.
And basically,
although they cover every surface,
the majority of them are in
the intestine. So today, uh,
I'm going to focus on the gut microbiome,
which,
and because that's the major
site of the human microbiome.
So what it,
what is this track look like?
We have about seven meters of small
intestine, two meters of large intestine,
and about 32 meters squared of Mucosa
surface for the bacteria to adhere to
along this tract,
uh,
within the large intestine and the
colon bacteria reach densities of one
[inaudible] 11 to [inaudible]
12 cells per milliliter.
This is one of the most dense microbial
ecosystems on the, on the planet.
And it's right inside of
you. Uh, I need total,
we think that there's about a little over
about a hundred trillion bacteria per
person that are residing on you
and making up your microbiome,
but the bacteria are not
just the cells there,
the genetic content thing code as well.
And here at Google in
particularly delighted to talk
about, uh, the microbiome,
which was originally coined as a word
to describe the genetic content of a,
of a, of a community of organisms. Um,
because actually we started learning about
these biomes through sequencing their
DNA. Um, and it's really the information
content that I think is one of,
at the forefront of understanding what
the microbiome is doing. So in total,
we've cataloged about 10 million genes
that are present in gut bacteria.
In any given person,
you have about 4 million.
And if you remember back from your
high school biology textbooks,
humans have around 20,000 genes.
So the bacteria genetically
outpaced us by almost 200 fold.
As we started to learn
over the last decade,
really the research has picked up along
with the advent of next generation
sequencing technology. The microbiome
has incredible effects on metabolism,
immunity and cognition.
And I just kind of labeled these three
as areas where the research is pushing
out the farthest.
But I would challenge you to talk about
areas of human physiology and wellbeing
that don't touch on metabolism,
immunity, and cognition.
But one fact I would like to change a
set straight for the record is one of you
might've heard originally that there
were 10 times more bacterial cells than
human cells.
It's one of the favorite things that we
started talking about in the microbiome
space, but unfortunately this is not
quite true. And some great work, uh,
in 2016 counted,
estimated all the cells that are present
in a human and all of the cells that
aren't,
might be present a of bacteria and found
that the ratio is much closer to one to
one.
And actually one of my favorite lines
from this paper was that with each
desiccation event,
uh,
you may flip the ratio to favor
human cells over bacteria.
So every poop matters.
And really one of,
one of the things I really
like to think about, uh,
to help visualize the diversity is come
take a look at this updated tree of life
from 2016.
So this was the,
a great paper that came out that
kind of shows off the major kingdoms,
including the bacteria in
the top, uh, are in blue,
are red archaea and eukaryotes in green.
So in that tiny tip that I've
drawn a red box around,
we have our animal plants and fungi. So
that's an incredible, just think about it,
like that's an incredible
diversity already.
And the distances on this tree
reflect evolutionary distance.
So if you, the animals, plants
and fungi are very diverse,
but they only occupy
that tiny little space.
Imagine how different all the rest of
this microscopic life is from each other.
It's a really hard,
hard concept to imagine because you can't,
they all look like single cells,
but they're incredibly different in
their membrane structure, their enzymes,
their physiology.
And so this is showing all bacteria
or all life that we know about.
If you check out the
right side of that tree,
you'll see all those red dots indicating
that we've never isolated or cultured a
micro organism from major families there.
But I pointed out a few members
of the human gut microbiome.
So in the bottom left we have very Kolai.
So the gamma proteobacteria,
these guys are one of the first
model organisms for microbiology,
easily cultured from the
human gut. Uh, coming up,
we have the Verruca Microbia,
which contains members
such as Akkermansia, Mucin,
Ophelia Mucin,
Ophelia for mucin lover.
This guy hangs out on the Mucosa
and it's a mucin specialist.
Above there, we have the most numerically
dominant members of the Gut microbiome,
the bacteria dailies,
specifically the genus bacteroidetes.
These guys are less diverse,
but the most abundant members of your
human gut microbiome and polysaccharide
utilizers. Uh, continuing
on over to the right,
we end up into the grand positives.
It's just the actino bacteria. Uh,
and there you have examples
such as bifidobacterium,
which are some of the first
colonizers of the infant gut.
And further to the right,
the from Mickey D's,
a very diverse member file
family of bacteria where,
which make up the most
diversity of the human gut. Um,
although there are less
abundant than the bacteroidetes,
I should also mention the bacteria
are not the end of the, of um,
the gut gut microbiome.
You also have eukaryotes present as well
as archaea and particularly the archaea
methe antigens are very important
for nutrients cycling in the Gut.
But today we're gonna focus on
the micro biome as a whole entity.
And why I think it's the most,
one of the most applicable analogies
to it is that I'd say microbial Oregon
system. And so you start off, um,
unborn fetuses are sterile and at
birth they're colonized either from the
vaginal canal,
um,
or from the skin during
[inaudible] section.
And so you can either,
you can see that the composite,
one of these little circles are that
are associated with each of these life
stages or compositions showing off the
amount of from Mickey D's and pink,
the backdoor idds in light blue,
the actino bacteria and
blue and proteobacteria and
red and the microbial organ
system undergoes
development as cu develop.
So as a baby,
it's a nascent Oregon.
It's mostly dominated by bifido bacteria.
With the introduction of solid food,
the bacteroidetes start showing up
as your time in adolescence, you may
be subject to antibiotic treatment,
which will alter the composition.
Um, you may also be malnourished,
which can delay the development
of your gut, microbial Oregon.
Uh, furthermore, as well,
by the time you transition through
puberty and into adulthood,
your microbiome stabilizes
and becomes uniquely you.
Each of you has a distinct microbiome
that's almost as identifying or more
identifying than a fingerprint.
Um,
and some of the major differences we can
see in the composition and adult have
to do with obese versus healthy, some
macro differences. And then finally,
as you become elderly, the diversity
of your microbiome starts to decline.
And we're not quite sure
what the effects of that are,
but people are looking into it.
And it may have,
we may be able to help ameliorate
some of the effects of old age through
restoring microbiome since a microbial
Oregon and similar to your other organs.
It structured both by your
environment and your inheritance.
So here I've just shown off,
I've talked about a few of the features
that impact the structure from the
environment, but others, uh,
particularly at the infant are [inaudible]
versus at vaginal antibiotic exposure,
breast milk versus formula feeding.
There's particular milk
oligosaccharides in mother's milk,
which only bacteria can digest.
And some of the milk,
a formula providers are starting to try
to try to put these sugars into their
milk formulas now, but they'd
been missing in the past. Um,
there's also additional factors such
as BMI or weight gain during pregnancy.
And the results of all of these in,
and I mentioned to you also,
you get an initially
colonize from your mother.
The results of this inheritance
and environmental factors
produce distinct a gut
microbiome compositions
in different populations.
So shown on the right is a principal
component analysis showing different gut
microbiome compositions
from United States, adults,
Malawi and adults or Amerindians.
And here you can see that the
u s population is distinct
from the Malawian and
Amerindian despite having multiple,
everyone having a unique
gut composition are,
we have a lot of functional redundancy.
So shown on the left is the composition
by Fila with the backdoor ids and blue
and then for making,
using green and proteobacteria in yellow.
And these are just a adults from
the human gut microbiome project.
And you can see that there's like people
who are dominated by backdoor ADTs.
There's some that have a balance of
from Mickey D's and backdoor idds.
But despite these
differences in composition,
all of them have almost the exact same
functional genes present in their gut
microbiome.
So when I think about this,
I think about it as maybe
two different junkyards.
One of tractors and one of cars,
uh,
but both have the functional wheels and
engines is an analogy I like to use here.
One of the things that really got me
into gut microbiome research was even
through my graduate for a hundred over
a hundred years since snow and cholera,
uh,
the bacteria have been seen as a problem,
a disease causing vectors that are just,
uh, harmful to humans. And that's really
catalyze a lot of research into bacteria.
But it leaves people with the
impression that bacteria are bad.
And one of the great things about the
microbiome is it demonstrates that not all
bacteria are bad.
Many of them are commensals.
They just live on us and
they don't really do much.
They don't interact with as much,
and some of them are even beneficial.
And we established these
symbiotic interactions between
beneficial bacteria and
ourselves. So we have our cast of
characters like salad, Gutchen, Manila,
uh,
that's when you've eaten the potato
salad that set out too long and others.
And so what's the secret? Why can
we coexist with all these bacteria,
many of which could be harmful to us.
And I think the answer comes from, uh,
that from a poem by Robert Frost,
that good friend fences
make good neighbors.
And so here you see two neighbors making
a wall together and they talk about in
the poem talks about how building this
wall helps encourage friendly behaviors
even though it's sending up a barrier
between them. And so similarly,
there's a wall in the gut microbiome
shown here is one of the most fascinating
images I think have been produced of
the human gut microbiome. Actually,
I should say this is a mouse
model of the gut microbiome,
but with a complex flora.
Uh,
the big green section is the Mucosal
mucin barrier that kind of serves us a no
man's land between bacteria and you.
Carrots in the blue is dappy staining of
Mammalian of the eukaryotic cell cells,
their nuclei. And in the top left you
see this huge mixture of bacteria,
um,
all different kinds mixed together.
And you can see that the mucin is
almost completely devoid of bacteria.
And this even looking
like a laminar structure.
And you can see that one of the
laminar pieces is sloughing off.
And starting to be
digested by the bacteria.
So the host makes the
mucin and it's stops the,
it serves as a barrier to protect the
host from constantly interacting with
microbial signals,
which could be harmful.
I think I'll just say a little bit more
about this mucin barrier cause it's just
really incredible that the, uh, it's not,
it's not only a physical barrier by just
being too dense to enabled penetration.
It is a chemical barrier in
that antimicrobial proteins
and other antimicrobial
particles are secreted from the host
into them into the mucin and serve as a
chemical determinitive
microbial colonization.
We've now been able to show that phages
which are viruses that eat bacteria
preferentially adhere to mucus and
serve as little by little like, uh,
I don't know what you'd call them. Uh, uh,
bombs in the mucus waiting for any
bacteria to come too close to them.
So you have chemical, you've got phage
barrier. And in addition to these,
uh,
antimicrobial properties,
it also serves as a major source
of nutrients for the bacteria.
And so that mucin that's sloughing off
is actually being digested and promoting.
The mucin is decorated with particular
sugars that promote the metabolism of
beneficial bacteria. So this is
just really an incredible barrier,
but I think it also helps to show you
that there's an incredible Mulu of
bacteria that are functioning and we,
they're separated from
the host by this mucin.
One more picture from the same paper I
mentioned that the Mucin can serve as a,
as a food source.
And so shown here on the left are
mice that are fed a standard diet that
includes polysaccharides and fiber.
And then on the right is mice that are
fed a diet that's deficient in fiber.
And you can see that the mucin
barrier in the right is dissolving.
The microbes without dietary fiber
are starting to eat away and penetrate
further and further into the mucin. So
eats your, eat your fruits and vegetables,
folks for your gut,
your gut microbiome.
So what aspects,
what's particular aspects do we know
about the human gut microbiome and health?
I think in 2006, it started
really kicking off with, uh,
Peter Turnball from Jeffrey Gordon's lab
showing that you could take obese stool
from humans,
put it into a germ free mouse,
and the mouse would develop obesity.
You could take stool from a lean human,
colonize a mouse with it,
and then that mouse would remain lean,
suggesting that there was a BCA,
obesity associated gut microbiome.
And we've went on to find more
things about the gut microbiome.
2008 Sarkis Mazmanian showed that
there was a microbial symbiosis factor,
a polysaccharide that was produced by
one of those beneficial bacteria that was
highly anti-inflammatory
and would prevent a audit.
Inflammatory diseases such as
inflammatory bowel disease.
We found that some bacteria can outcompete
pathogens such as bifidobacteria.
We find that,
as I said,
the gut microbiome develops and if
you're malnourished, it doesn't develop.
And in fact, when the, you've
go to malnourished children, uh,
in Malawian and you try to give them
ready to eat foods like peanut butter,
they don't get better. You need to
repair their microbiome before they can.
The food will allow them
to become not malnourished.
There's also more recently, uh, we've
known that microbiome is converting,
um,
chemicals that are derived from
red meat into their Metabo.
The microbes are metabolizing them into
a chemical called Tmao that promotes
heart as thorough sclerosis, otherwise
known as heart disease. And finally,
there's some great work going on also
in the Mazmanian lab by Elaine Zau
demonstrating that some of the Microbiota
differences you can observe in mice
lead to neurodevelopmental disorders. And
so this is an autism spectrum, just um,
a model in mice and fire.
And additionally,
I think we're also finding type one
diabetes and other inflammatory autoimmune
disorder. So you can see that this
hasn't happened to deal with metabolism,
immunity,
cognition.
One of the diseases we know about the
most in the microbiome is clostridium
difficile. C difficile is a hospital
acquired infection that we heard about.
It can,
it can kill about 30,000 Americans a year.
It costs $5 billion in hospital
costs and it's been rising,
although I think actually
do open biomes work.
It's been falling lately with c difficile.
You can take antibiotics,
but it's a spore forming organism.
So even if you are able to
remove the vegetative cells,
the spores are antibiotic resistant
and they can remain in the gut and then
germinate again.
And so antibiotics have some
efficacy but they don't cure.
So about 30% of the time there'll be
effective in curing cedar for seal.
And the way this is working, I think I'll
just explain this little diagram here.
I think this is a really appropriate
model for fecal microbiota transplant.
You start with a healthy microbiome,
which can be perturbed by antibiotics,
which we need to take because some of
these bacteria or pathogens and they'll
kill you. So you need antibiotics.
Let's not make any mistakes about that.
But as you're doing that,
antibiotics are like nuclear bomb
shells on the microbial world.
They're just killing
everything and hopefully,
and most times the bacteria are able
to grow back and restore a healthy
microbiome.
But sometimes you,
with this clear cutting of the,
of the microbial eco ecosystem,
you can get a,
we'd like c difficile infecting and
overgrowing and preventing return to a
normal healthy microbiome. And this can
lead to more antibiotic treatment to cut,
to get rid of the infection, which
is causing horrible diarrhea. Uh,
but then that leads right back into
another round of c difficile disease.
And so one of the most
effective treatments you
can do is take a whole fecal
microbiota transplant,
put it into a person,
and just restore the healthy ecosystem.
And that actually has about a 98
around a 90% cure rate for CDF.
It's an incredible improvement
over antibiotics. So,
but one of the problems is access,
cause that's,
you mentioned FMT used
to be pretty sketchy.
People would get blenders and give
each other a transplants by having the
roommate poop into a blender, grind it up
and then like give themselves an enema.
That's not a very safe way
to do fecal transplants.
But I'm showing here a picture
of Mark Smith and James Burgess,
the cofounders of OpenBiome.
Mark had a friend who was suffering from
c-diff and he just did not have access
to a clinician who could
provide a fecal transplant.
The clinicians are worried
about, uh, whether it's safe,
they don't know how to do it.
Um,
but mark was working on this in the lab
and he knew that FMTs could help his
friend, but he just couldn't get
them from anywhere. So with James,
they decided to make open biome to provide
access to FMT using a universal donor
model. So the universal
donor model, what is that?
That's the model where instead of trying
to find one specific person who's maybe
you live with so that you'd have a similar
gut microbiome and trying to screw,
make sure that they don't have any
infectious diseases that you could get and
screening that one person individually
and then trying to get a fecal transplant
done. Instead, what you do
is use open up a stool bank,
a you taking use heavily screened donors
and you enable everyone to provide,
uh, enable very healthy donors to
provide stool that can then be given to
clinicians,
should just be used as a treatment instead
of relying on the clinician's knowing
about how to do the screening
and how to do the preparation.
And so OpenBiome has been incredibly
successful at scaling the universal donor
model.
It provided over 25,000 treatments in
950 hospitals and clinics and opened by
owns network in all 50 states
and in seven countries,
including the u s and as part of this,
the universal stool donor program.
That's kind of why I'm here today to help
tell you about this and encourage you
to become a part of this program.
There's an incredible dropoff because
when there's a lot of screening that's
done, there's a prescreen survey in
which about 66% of people pass just,
um, looking at lifestyle
associated conditions.
There's a clinical assessment in
which 84% are make it through.
And then finally laboratory testing,
which results in another only 47% getting
through to results in a total of only
2.8% of our donors who apply,
being able to be a stool donor.
So this is a very tight pipeline,
but it can be very effective.
So I encourage you to give
poop at gift pooped out Org.
You can save lives,
earn money,
and donate your stool and make
your morning routine heroic.
I think one of the most exciting things
that we're doing at finch and OpenBiome
is looking about looking ahead to
find out what new diseases might fecal
transplants be effective for.
And so I'll just share with you
a small vignette about alopecia.
Alopecia is an autoimmune disease in
which you start to lose your hair,
uh,
and or all hair on your body.
And so shown here as a patient
at 16 years old on the,
on the far left starting to lose hair.
Um,
then this patient unfortunately also
contracted c difficile and then received a
fecal transplant and as a result,
and so this middle picture shows him right
before receiving the fecal transplant.
And then after the fecal transplant,
his he notices hair started to regrow.
And these have now been,
this one anecdote has now become two
anecdotes and we're very interested in
following up on it. Ask
for one example, but uh,
this kind of shows you how connected the
gut microbiome is to our overall health
and ways that we can't know today.
But we're hoping to discover tomorrow.
And so without a leave you by saying
that we're OpenBiome and finch or focused
on safe access, clinical research,
perpetual access and new cures.
Thank you.
Okay.
Now have some time for
questions and answers and nod.
Like I'll also introduce and meg,
Meg Megan food.
Did I mispronounce your last
name horribly? Yeah. Meg Is, uh,
one of our ex on our external
affairs team at OpenBiome. Yeah,
we screen for a lot of
different conditions. Um,
and you do have to have a BMI under 30.
If you want to become a stool donor.
The front,
why is the,
why is the pipeline so narrow that you
really have to be that careful? Is that
what makes it so narrow?
Why is the pipeline so narrow?
What partly because there's research
indicating that the gut microbiome is
related to pretty much everything.
Um,
partly because a lot of people tend to
carry conditions they don't know about.
Um, when we test for still note are the
people that we reject that don't make it
through rather, um, aren't
necessarily unhealthy.
But there are people who are carrying a
transmission of disease or some sort of
condition that we think might harm
the people with C diff. I mean,
two things to remember here. One, we're
regulated by the FDA, which has very,
very strict standards and to the
people who are getting fecal microbiota
transplants are really,
really sick. You know,
fecal Microbiota transplants are
only approved for recurrent CDI.
C diff infections,
not the initial C diff infection.
So by the time they get to us,
they've already been through at
least two rounds of antibiotics,
typically had this disabling
diarrhea for three, four, five,
six months or even longer in some cases.
So we can't take any chances that,
oh,
that little noro virus that you happen
to carry that doesn't cause you any
problems.
Could could kill this person who's already
in a very delicate state of health.
So,
um,
that's why it's narrow and we can't
predict who's going to make it through the
pipeline or not.
You know,
some people are Gung Ho rowers
and need a perfect fiber diet.
Some people just kind of munch
French fries and walk around,
but they for some reason have this
really great gut microbiome and aren't
carrying any, anything we don't
want in there is we can't predict.
That's why we have to ask all
of you to apply. And there,
do we have to match donor recipient?
No, that's the wonderful thing. Um,
as long as the person isn't carrying
some sort of disease or has some sort of
condition we think might make you
sick or pretty much anyone will do,
it's really amazing.
It'll,
it'll all work in C diff and
it works about 90% of the time.
That is not necessarily true for
other conditions. Um, open biome,
we have a dual mission of providing safe
access to fecal microbiota transplants
for c diff but also
promoting clinical research.
And we're currently involved in the
30 different clinical research trials
looking to things like inflammatory
bowel disease, Crohn's disease,
even peanut allergies and one case.
And there's some indication from some of
our work on types of inflammatory bowel
disease that there are differences
between donors and their effectiveness in
promoting remissions. So for seed, if it
doesn't matter for other things it might,
we're not sure yet, which is why
we're doing all this research.
Hi,
a wonderful talk.
I was wondering if you could tell us
anything about what either known or
theorize,
but the mechanisms between
the gut microbiome and any
of these other conditions
such as obesity or the,
the hair loss or either known or
theorized about that, those connections.
So sometimes we're digging into specific
mechanisms and sometimes it's not
known. So particularly in
the obesity case, it was,
there was a investigation
into the metallic metabolic
genes and we were able to
see that there is an over abundance of
metabolic genes associated with energy
harvest suggesting that potentially the,
um,
microbes are just liberating or make it
so you'd have this fiber that's good,
but normally it's just exclude screened.
And they used us with
food for the bacteria,
but they may be producing metabolites
which can then be absorbed by the human
host, um, and that may be providing
more energy from a given set of food.
Um,
and actually those metabolites are
also potentially underlying some of the
inflamed inflammation parts.
So I mentioned there was a specific
polysaccharide that was released by
bacteroidetes,
which was in anti-inflammatory,
but that's a pretty specific one.
One of the most general mechanisms,
uh, that's well known is the production
of these short chain fatty acids like
butyrate at appropriate Nate,
which are just small little carbons
that result from the breakdown of
polysaccharides.
And many bacteria in the gut can release
those and they serve as actually the
primary food source for your
colonic endothelial cells.
And so not only do they help the cells,
how by providing their
preferred metabolite,
they can also trigger
a specific receptors,
g of protein receptors in immune
cells to have diverse effects.
But the results of which are generally
the production of anti inflammatory
cytokines and the reprogramming of immune
cells away from inflammation towards
tolerance.
And people are looking at this,
these immune effects of the gut
microbiome in an astonishing number of
conditions.
There's some really interesting research
coming out about the gut microbiome and
multiple sclerosis and
Parkinson's disease.
And there a couple of really interesting
papers that came out just last week
about um,
mediation mediating in cancer treatments
and evolved immune system that some
people who have certain type of Gut
Microbiota chemotherapy as much more
effective. And if you take their gut
microbiome and put them in germ free mice,
you find the same differences in the
mice as you did between people when they
undergo cancer treatments. So anything
having to do the immune disease, it just,
anything that's pretty astonishing.
Yeah.
So there was a paper in nature,
I believe 2014 about the effect of um,
the sugar substitutes on the
gut microbes and resulting hmm.
Um, resulting a metabolic
syndrome symptoms essentially,
which could be transferred from
mouse to a mouse by, by, uh,
by fecal transplant.
Seems like the sort of thing that we both
known to you and flashy and shocking.
We've been followed up by
other researchers by now.
What's latest in that area?
So actually no,
that paper pretty well.
It was fascinating because
it's like one of the,
these are artificial sweeteners that are
supposed to be not metabolized, right?
So they're supposed to be calorie
free, uh, but still have sweetness.
But one of the things that means by not
metabolized normally sugars are like
digested and the simple ones are
dissolved almost out of your mouth. Like,
and if not by then in at least in
the, um, in the small intestine. Uh,
but these ones make,
are not,
and they make their way straight down
into the gut microbiome, the colon.
And there they were shown to have an
effect on promoting a signaling that would
lead to like metabolic disorder in
mice. There's, I haven't seen that.
There's been new updates on that story.
Um,
I think one of the caveats
there is that they were,
I tried to calculate how much artificial
sweetener they were feeding the mice.
And I think it was somewhere
around like if you were a human,
you need to have like
70 packages of, uh, ah,
which one was it? I won't, I won't say
which one so I don't get in trouble.
But like one, whichever one it was,
didn't need to open 70 packets.
I need that much to get the same dosing
that was being applied to the month
mouse.
Um,
also the other interesting part is
they didn't just feed it to the mice.
They took the bacteria out
and they dosed the bacteria,
grew it with this artificial sweetener
as the sole nutrient source for awhile
and then they transplanted it back.
And then the community had these
different signaling effect soon as a few
caveats there,
but it definitely hinted that these
artificial sweeteners may not,
while they may be calorically in are
they may have a strong signaling effect
mediated by the microbiome.
Fun fact about mouse
experiments in the microbiome.
Mice do their own fecal transplants
if they want us together,
much like dogs do sometimes.
There was another question in front
research and irritable bowel syndrome.
We certainly are.
If you're interested in any clinical
trials of fecal microbiota transplants,
clinical trials.gov, uh, you
can put in on the search term,
your condition and then FMT or fecal
microbiota transplant or just fecal and
you'll come up with list of trials.
I know there are a couple
of running in Boston,
probably Doctor Jessica Allegretti
ready at Brigham and women's,
but don't quote me on that. Um,
look it up on clinical trials.gov.
Any other questions?
Could you speak more as to what you're
looking for in the pipeline that you
mentioned earlier?
Uh, so in each of these
stages, I think they're,
I mean, maybe you might be the
right person for through this. Yeah,
like on a regular basis.
The donor survey has a variety of
questions about lifestyle risk.
So maybe are you monogamous?
Um,
no, no, no, no.
Oh,
okay.
Honestly,
um,
they've updated it.
Yeah.
We really want to know that you live in
Boston or Cambridge or somewhere around
here. First of all, because we get a lot
of people applying and say, this is cool.
I live in Paraguay. I'm like, no, you
cannot send us your poop in the mail.
Don't even think about it. So
that's, that's her primary criterion.
Can you actually get to one of our donor
sites and we have donor sites at inner
belt road in Somerville and your Sullivan
Square Station and one in central
square.
Very convenient to Google headquarters
and another one at Bu West if you're on
that side of the river. Um, and
they're open every day of the week. Um,
and they're very convenient and they're
staffed by friendly people. Um, you know,
we're looking to see are healthy.
Um,
if you have a history of colitis
or inflammatory bowel disease,
this isn't what you should be
doing. Um, but overall it's,
it's about health. And again, there
are things that you may be carrying.
A lot of people carry parasites
without knowing it, you know,
hominids or something like that.
And you can't tell that until you got
to the end of the clinical interview and
gone through blood and stool screening
because he wa you wouldn't ask your
doctor, you know, he wouldn't say, Hey,
can you just test me for parasites?
You have no reason to suspect,
but again,
you could be carrying something that
could make someone very sick. Um,
we test for more than 30 different
conditions and we have a rather lengthy
questionnaire that people go through
before they even go to the nurse.
So it's hard for me to summer
as as it right now. And, um,
but if you're curious,
go to give poop.org register and we
will probably point you to a copy of the
questionnaire and you can see for yourself
other questions,
uh, that just prompted one. When
you say you do all the testing,
do you give the results to the donor
or is that just used internally?
If we abide by HIPPA regulations and if
we find anything new about your health
that you do not tell us about.
Like if we get the stool and blood
sample back and say, Hey, wait a minute,
this person is positive for HIV for
example, we certainly tell you. But, um,
if it just comes back that it's
something he said, oh by the way,
I got hepatitis last year and you
come back positive for hepatitis,
we would call you. Um, but generally we
don't find anything new. Most people,
um, are excluded from donation,
not because of anything new,
but because of something that could
affect the people who are getting the
transplants,
like having a family history of colitis.
Yeah, I came in late and missed the
talk. So I'm going to ask a question,
which might have been the last,
what assays do you perform on the samples?
Genetic essays,
sequencing such,
yeah, that's a great
question. So as I mentioned,
the reason we start to know so much about
the gut microbiome is because of next
generation sequencing technology. And so
particularly the two types of sequences,
we generally perform our
16 s amplicon sequencing.
So here every bacteria
has a specific gene.
It was called the 16 s ribosomal RNA gene.
And here,
because each one of them has it,
you can use it as a marker for
how they're related to each other.
And that can give you an overall
picture of the community,
but it doesn't get a high enough
resolution because everyone has it.
It doesn't change fast enough to really
let you get down into the species much
less the strains.
So bacteria with identical 16 s gene
sequences could have up to like 20 to 30%
of their genome will be different.
So the other type of sequencing we do
is called shotgun and Meta genomics.
And here instead of starting with a PCR
preliminary chain reaction to target a
specific gene,
you just look at every single piece
of DNA that you can find and start
sequencing it. And that gives you
a piece here, a piece there, uh,
and they're hard.
It's much more computationally difficult
to understand the results of shotgun
sequencing,
but it's can get you down into the
strain level composition of the gut
microbiome.
I'll follow up and ask exactly what do
you do a assembly technology do you use
to try and ask say
these shotgun sequences?
I used store the bloat institute across
the street as a building genome assembly
tool.
So that's my interest.
Yeah. Unfortunately, I don't think I can
say much about that for two reasons. One,
I'm mostly on the microbial
isolation side. Uh,
I'm really hoping to improve
my computational skills,
but I just couldn't speak confidently
about the different pipelines that are
being used right now, uh, by
our data science team. Um,
I'd happy to be put in touch with sunny
at Timberlake who is our director of
data science. It could maybe say some
more about that. Thank you very much.
Thank you.